So anyway, uh, what was I gonna say? Oh yeah,
this is the thing I really wanted to do though.
This is the thing I really wanted to play. This killed me, bro. This like,
all right, when you have a job and you're not into it, that's common, you know?
But you think of someone in a cubicle or you think of someone, you know,
like ups guy, just going through the motions. If you're a
pastor, I don't know what this guy is. You.
Think by the blood of the lamb.
This guy is a preacher. A preacher is what it is.
Now. A lot of you've probably seen this, I guess. I don't know. But dude,
this guy is sitting, first of all, he's sitting down, dude,
if you're a preacher, stand the up. Dude also don't dress like Garth Brooks,
this guy's dressed like, so
this guy, literally it looks like he's about to sing in front of 400, 400,
4,000, 40,000 people, a country music. Okay.
I pray. I pray. I pray. I pray.
I pray. I pray. Deliverance, deliverance, deliverance, deliverance,
deliverance stuff.
Y'all guy get new words. You know,
you don't need to say deliverance. Deliverance delivers deliverance,
deliverance. All right. So he checks his phone. Number one right now.
Here we go. Checks his phone.
Oh Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord.
Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord.
[inaudible]. Yes, Lord
. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord.
[inaudible]
shine your way. Have your way, have your way, have your way,
uh.
Checking his phone. He's checking his phone.
If you're listening to this and not watching it, he's checking his phone.
And then.
Uh.
These are the things on the table, his phone, his glasses,
a bottle of water and olive oil. Okay.
Getting texts from his wife saying,
uh, uh, go back to yes Lord.
Yes, Lord. Uh,
[inaudible] realized he was like, Oh, wait. I got to say some words.
Uh, Oh that was when his wife said she's leaving.
She's leaving. And when he said hallelujah, she said,
she's leaving the flat-screen right here.
Uh
[inaudible] uh, at this point.
I guess a waiter or something picks up the olive oil and wipes the table down.
And what the is going on? A Fellini movie?
Uh, uh
[inaudible] hallelujah.
[inaudible] hallelujah. Hallelujah. Hallelujah. Thank you, Lord. Thank you,
Lord. God, touch this, touch this right now. Touch this situation.
Touch this situation by the power of God.
Touch the situation by the power of the Holy ghost by the anointing,
by the anointing, by the anointing, by the anointing.
[inaudible] Kay, do that though.
Juvenile? No master P
uh [inaudible] dude. I could do that, man. The why you doing?
What the, dude. That's so dumb. Hey man.
First of all, be in a better place. Number two. Don't dress like that.
Number three. Clear the table. Number four.
Don't check your phone number. Lamp
stand up. And the number six. Don't do this.
Uh, short of breath.
Uh.
[Inaudible] Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, Lord. Yes, yes, yes, yes, Lord. Yes. Yes.
Deliver us from, deliver us from evil [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] biscuit.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] shimmy. Shimmy, shimmy, shimmy, shimmy, shimmy. Shimmy. Yeah. From,
from, from, from, from, from
[inaudible] what will remember me? She had it in my car from remember,
remember roomed in my car room from a room.
It in my car. Master P dude S masterpiece,
Dude, what the is he doing?
Like straight up.
The preacher.
The preacher dude.
[Inaudible] mom's such a dude. Get a real job.
The Lord had nothing to do with that. You know,
the Lord was literally texting him. Stop. That's why I checked his phone.
Wow. That made me laugh. When I first saw that I roar.
And that's it.
Let's see what the comments say, dude. That's some favorite.
Uh.
I know there's like four people clapping, which is the best. Wow.
Somebody said he went from speaking tongues to orgasms. Kay. Uh Oh wow.
Somebody said he just stops talking and starts channeling master P. Okay, cool.
Great. I'm a hack. Cool. I had no idea if were saying what I was thinking. Cool.
Yeah. Oh, and the other one is just the opposite.
And does the person have to pick the time that the spirit is moving to clean the
table? My son just asked if he was playing Pokemon go. I don't get that part,
but wow dude,
just unbelievable. Dude. Preachers are hilarious.
Let's look up some other ones.
Preacher's preacher. Uh, what do I do? Preaching.
Okay. These guys are such. Even the good ones.
Look, look at these titles. Stop blocking your miracle. Kay.
Wow. Who is this guy? Tony Evans.
Okay.
One far is telling me to look up Benny Hinn. Oh, is that the guy with the coat?
That Oh yeah, this guy's great. Oh, this guy's great, dude.
Oh, this is great. Benny Hinn, historic crusades, Atlanta in 2010,
this guy keeps on whipping people with his jacket and they think they're getting
saved. First of all, I look at this.
He looks like he will be on the show. See quest in 1996. That simple.
Oh yeah.
[Inaudible].
Wow. Dude. He's tossing his blazer at people. Oh wow.
These people are getting ruptured discs falling on the ground. No.
If this guy did this to me, I would stand there. Look at, look at it again.
The Lord has nothing to do with blazers. Okay.
Oh.
Oh. Has a control. Oh, she has a control freak. Watch, watch, watch.
As I said, quick.
Hands. I said quick
Take that audience.
[Inaudible].
Cunty said cunty in it. Hey man said Conti.
Oh wow. This is a salt straight up. He just smashed the girl in the face.
The guy singing, you know?
Oh David, Brent, how we dance? Oh dude.
Yo. I mean the way the guy in the back, just going
[inaudible] while the guy just take that, show me a heads. Take that.
Nothing.
Was happening. You know, don't do all this.
Just chill place. The Doko wow.
This guy keeps doing this. If this guy did this to me, I'd lay him out.
Wow. Everyone is doing it too. It looks like Jeff Foxworthy. It's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable, dude.
They all have the Jeff Foxworthy starter kit or whatever. The,
the guy in the back is the best dude. How he knows his.
He just keeps killing it with the song.
You just said, what happened? What happened?
She had rheumatoid arthritis and here we go. Heal them tonight.
Here we go. Just putting their faces in.
And they fell to the ground was so rude and they still have rheumatoid
arthritis. That's interesting. And it gonna push their face again to the ground.
And these idiots are buying these idiots.
Everyone hears the he's a freaking idiot.
Unbelievable dude. Let's just hear him talk a little bit
of the Lord.
Because I.
Guarantee you, this guy had a three episode arc on sea quest in 1998.
Now I want to, I want to begin by sharing a story that I,
I want to talk to you about. I was many years ago,
I was many years ago preaching for my friend, Mela, Nikki and I,
we all love Melanie. Kay. She, she she's my,
one of my sweetest friends in the whole world. Well, I went to Denver, Colorado.
This was 84, 85. I walked down the aisle.
I look at a lady. I said, lady bombing.
The Lord tells me you have cancer. And she says, no, I don't.
I said, yes you do. She said, no, I don't. I said, yes,
you do Charleston. We got into an argument.
Now Melanie is killing on the platform, getting all upset with me killing.
I said, lady, the Lord told me you have cancer. She said, no, I don't. I said,
yes I do. She said, no, I don't. I said yes. And I said, listen.
I said,
if I am wrong on God talking to me about you I'll quit the ministry.
I was dead bold. I said,
don't you tell me you don't when the Lord tells me you do.
Okay. You're crazy. I said, I am not leaving till you admit you have it.
Oh wow.
Because when the Lord speaks to us.
That guy is in a relationship.
We know he's spoke.
Look, look, there's all the black people in our like mm that's. Right. Yeah.
And the way people are like, okay, well we'll, we'll see.
And I said to the lady, I said, now lady, I said,
or God has not spoken to me or you're lying.
Well, you can imagine the tension in the auditorium by that. Or you're crazy.
Dear Mela NICU was sitting on the platform getting ready.
And the white people go, yes, ma'am.
Well, she and I talked about this, but anyways, the lady
had just heard a preacher who preached on
faith and who said to the congregation,
don't confess it.
And now the lady starts to weep too loud.
And the whole church heard her say to me,
I am not supposed to say it. I am not supposed to say it.
And then I got really angry.
That's not lady.
Faith does not deny fact.
Uh, yeah, it does. Actually.
He ever came to Jesus and said, I'm not supposed to say it.
Jesus.
Ah, this moron. What a,
just robbing people, you know,
robbing poor people of money because they want to believe in something. Well,
that's not far from what we're doing.
You can get your life rips hoodies at crystal, leah.com.